This world is not yet ready for all that
you will do
your time will come diana
and everything will be different
citizens of the world i'm here to change
your life
anything you want
anything you dream of you can have it
you look like you saw a ghost
diana look at you it's like now one day
has passed
get used to it
i've never been one for rules the answer
is always more
the way i fly they will never find us i
forgot to tell you what
radar will they will they shoot at us?
barbara what did you do
you know i'm not so keen on this one i
figure uh you are but
you know what i'm ready to go i think we
can do better
parachute pants yeah um does everybody
parachute now
Welcome back everyone it's charlie happy
dc fandome you
made it we have a bunch of trailer
footage to break down this will be my
wonder woman 1984 trailer we have
full-blown comic book form cheetah
thankfully we do not have a cat's
situation on our hands so there's a
bunch of easter eggs we'll break it down
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
going to be a bunch more trailers
tonight including the batman and the
justice league snyder cut trailer
so we'll just start at the beginning and
go through the trailer shot by shot most
of this is new footage which is great
they start with the scene of the
flashback to the olympics on themyscira
when she was a little girl there's sort
of this parable that they tell
the story is all about greed and excess
because this is the 80s that we're in
during present day
like later in the trailer maxwell lord
couldn't say it better when he says to
cheetah
all i know is more more more i've never
been one for rules
that's sort of a theme of the movie
hippolyta gives her a similar lesson in
the flashbacks when she's a little girl
competing in these olympics like the
quick and easy way is the way to the
dark side to make a star wars reference
but then you get the hippolyta voiceover
saying the world is not yet ready for
all you can do
that's obviously a clever wink at all
the abilities that she has all of her
special powers i know everybody's asking
can she fly
because it seems like she flies a couple
different times during this trailer
and in the poster that they just
revealed yesterday she's also flying in
the golden armor because it has a set of
wings on it
like while the voice over is happening
she's running through the olympics but
they intercut her in present day
lassoing the lightning bolts which is
obviously totally crazy
then you see her running off of a
building in the gold armor before the
wings have unfurled
so clearly she's going to fly in that
gold armor but maxwell lord is then
using the president's address
system to broadcast his message all over
the world it's hard to say
exactly when this is happening during
the movie but it's probably happening
sometime near when this white house
fight between
cheetah and wonder woman is happening
because maxwell lord is there too
you just don't see him in this footage
it's just that she's there to protect
him so that he can give this message
using the president's broadcast system
i love while he's doing that too you go
all over the world you see all this 80s
technology all these old-timey computers
it's just great i love all the nostalgia
in this then he tells everyone around
the world you can have everything you
always wanted and they cut to the steve
trevor scene as she sees him for the
first time
because steve trevor is what wonder
woman wants so he comes back to life
literally then because cheetah is sort
of a parallel for wonder woman's arc
during the movie you get her voice over
she says i don't want to be like
everyone else i want to be an apex
predator
so all these cheetah scenes are meant to
be a dark mirror of all the wonder woman
scenes during the trailer
there's a scene of barbara minerva
listening to him this is i think from a
different part of the movie though but
she's inside the smithsonian where she
works
she has that voice over talking to
wonder woman after she starts to get
wonder woman's powers and becomes more
powerful but she's not full comic book
cheetah form yet she still looks like a
human
she tells wonder woman that she's always
had everything and people like barbara
minerva have never had
anything and that's going to change now
so she's basically in the process of
taking her powers over the course of the
film evolving
slowly through the film into the full
comic book cheetah form
while this is happening you see wonder
woman walk into the smithsonian offices
where she works with
cheetah but this is obviously while
cheetah is still barbara minerva
you get a bunch more of that white house
fight with her with the lasso of true
trying to take down those guards
this might be because maxwell lord
wishes himself to become the president
the wishing stone that they use that
special black rock that you saw in the
last trailer that's called the dream
stone that's basically what enables
everyone to get what it is that they
want with this big evil
genie twist it's kind of like a monkey's
paw situation you wish for something you
get it but you have to give up something
of yourself in return
that's why wonder woman is losing her
powers because she wants steve trevor
she gets him but then
in order to get him she has to give the
rock her powers and the rock gives her
powers to cheetah
the thing the cheetah winds up giving up
to get those powers is her humanity
literally and metaphorically like when
you see her fighting wonder woman i love
that she's wearing those crazy
leopard print clothes just foreshadowing
the full transformation into cheetah
you see wonder woman trying to use her
signature gauntlet move to stop cheetah
and she just jumps right through it
that's just because by this point in the
film she's gotten so weak that it
doesn't work quite as well and she has
gotten so much more powerful that she
can just jump right through it
then you see more of that footage of the
foreign situation that wonder woman is
trying to stop this big war that's
breaking out but she's gotten weaker so
she's having more trouble stopping it
while you have the parallel of cheetah
just starting to get her powers getting
stronger and faster like she takes off
into a run out of that hotel like oh my
god
it's basically the power montage that
you get in a lot of superhero films like
in man of steel when superman
is first learning about his abilities
and trying to learn how to fly
but because it's cheetah it's a little
bit darker like she takes down this
mugger and just feels so powerful oh
this is so amazing i'm going to be so
awesome now
then you have maxwell lord going full
darth sidious
to cheetah telling her more more more
who cares about rules
this is probably when cheetah makes her
second wish to become the full apex
predator and that's when she turns into
full comic book cheetah form
then you have wonder woman and steve
trevor trying to chase them down in
their plane stealing
this jet but steve trevor has this big
joke about being an amazing pilot
they'll never find us and then wonder
woman was like yeah i got to tell you
about that
they got some modern technology called
radar there's no way you can escape that
the footage of maxwell lord with the
wind blowing around him while he's using
that presidential address system is just
the magic of the dream stone working its
power
then you have wonder woman versus
cheetah in her gold armor and full
cheetah form so this structure seems
like it's this big giant broadcast tower
in this foreign country that they're all
flying to
but by this time it seems like wonder
woman has gotten most of her power back
after she sends steve trevor
back to death like she has to wish him
away in order to reverse
her wish and get her powers back and
it's the same for everybody all over the
world like chaos breaks out because
everyone around the world is making a
wish
wanting things as maxwell lord tells
them to do because he's manipulating
them
that's when you see all this chaos erupt
in the streets just because just crazy
stuff starts to happen to people
the cheetah fight seems pretty solid but
i believe she's supposed to end this
movie still being cheetah i don't think
they're completely ending that like they
were supposed to introduce her in the
first film and make her this really huge
villain so i think they have plans for
cheetah
way down the road that she could always
come back in a future movie then they
have that other joke tag scene like the
trash one from the last trailer where
steve trevor comes out in parachute
pants does everybody parachute now
what's going on
as funny as this is doesn't this remind
you of some of the costumes from
superman 4 the quest for peace
big surprise too patty jenkins actually
revealed that she wanted to introduce
cheetah during the first wonder woman
movie it would have happened at the end
of the film in
present day when she was at the louvre
just looking at the watch that steve
trevor gave her in the picture from
world war one
we do know they're going to make wonder
woman three and it's going to be set during
present day but they haven't said who
the main villain of that's going to be i
know a lot of people have been asking
for cersei so let me know in the
comments
who do you want the villain of wonder
woman 3 to be if it's going to be set in
present day
and which other justice league
characters do you want to see cross over
into that movie
because that's part of the reason why
you do films set in the same time period
so the characters can actually cross
over
but they've been releasing a bunch more
previews of that gold armor of hers
that's meant to be an heirloom that she
keeps with her from themyscira one of
her more famous ancestors just built it
out of the pieces of a bunch of other
amazon's armor
they claimed that when they were filming
it was the gold armor that was the big
secret
they tried to keep that secret while
they were doing the movie which i think
is kind of weird because you think that
comic book cheetah form is what they
would try to keep secret
kristen wiig even said that they
wouldn't let her take any pictures of
her cheetah costume when she was in full
cheetah makeup
but as you can see a lot of this is
special effects like she probably walked
around in motion capture with a bunch of
dots on her face and then they put this
on her later
but everyone let me know in the comments
what's your favorite part of this and
what are you most hyped up about for
wonder woman 1984.
obviously there's a bunch more trailers
coming today i think some of them even
leaked early but they've been taking
them down
so there's going to be a justice league
snyder cut trailer next there's a black
atom panel the rock has been teasing a
bunch of new footage for that
james gunn has a suicide squad panel and
he said he's going to show off a first
look
then matt reeves has a big batman panel
happening tonight there's going to be a
bunch of stuff happening
while you wait for everything click here
for my new justice league snyder cut
trailer video
and click here to learn all about ben
affleck coming back as batman in the dc
movies
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!